الفنان امير مصري احنا بنرحب بك معنا انت
في كوب 27 همم انا احنا شوفنا لك اعلان
وفيلم وترويج للقاب 27 عايزه اعرف انت هنا
ايه هي مهمتك وايه هو هدفك
اولا عندي مسؤوليه ان همم
استخدم البلاد فون بتاعي او صوتي همم لا
قضيه مهمه انا انا دائما كنت مهتم
بالحاجات الانسانيه انا اصلا كنت عامل
فيلم من سنتين اسمه كان همم كان بيحكي عن
اللاجئين معظم الناس فاكرين ان ان الاقيين
همم
هربانين عشان همم في حرب همم بس مش عارفين
اصلا ان كمان ممكن هرمين من ال- من ال-
همم من المناخ ف همم ده اللي انا مهتم بها
وايه وفخور جدا ان مصر همم
يعني بالنسبه لي من من اقوى الدول في
افريقيا هم الهوست السنه دي همم
فانا متفائل متفائل ان السنه دي هيبقى في
انجاز بدل ما يبقى في بث وعد همم
كمان برده الشباب
موجودين موجودين بقوه برده انا كمان سفير
للامم المتحده اللي هي مؤتمر اسمه شباب
بلد بندعم الشباب ان يشتغلوا همم
ولكن معظمهم مهتمين همم مؤتمر المناخ مش
بس عشان هم ماشي همم موجود في هممم همم هم
عايزين يساعدوا العالم بشكل عام انا
بالنسبه لي كلام ممثل انا حاسس ان قوه
الناعمه بتوصل الرساله ودي ما حصلش قبل
كده انا شايف ان الفيلم اللي احنا صورناه
كمان المشاهد اللي موجوده حاجاتها حصلت
حاجات موجوده دلوقت فاحنا بنستخدم همم
الشق بقى بنحاول نخض الناس اوريهم ان ده
بيحصل عشان يعرفوا ولكن في النهايه في
رساله ايجابيه
بنقول لو احنا اتجمعنا مع بعض
[موسيقى]
نقدر نغير انت عايش ما بين لندن وما بين
مصر وليك اعمال فنيه طبعا في مصر انت اخر
عملت الفنان هنا ايه
قولي انت عملت ايه بتعمل ايه
دلوقتي في فيلم اسمه هاشتاغ جوزني هو
دلوقتي
فيلم رومانسي انا بقى لي سنين كان نفسي
اعمل دور رومانسي قوي فالحمد لله ال- همم
الناس همم مبسوطين من الفيلم
بعد بكره كراون انت قايم بدور دودي الفايد
وهو صغير
ز الاخرانيه دي
انت حاسس هيستقبلوه ازاي لانه اوريدي لما
نزل البرومو كان في شويه هجوم علشان وفاه
الملكه اليزا انت متوقع ايه قبل قبل
الاحداث بس
لا هو انا شفت اول ثلاث حلقات ومتصور بشكل
فظيعه فظيع جدا والتمثيل فظيع لان انا
مبسوط منه كمان السنه دي ان في كميه همم
ممثلين من دول العربيه بالذات من مصر
موجودين في فيلم المسلسل